[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض ولكن اقدم من خلالها ابرز اخبار
وملفات السعوديه والخليج وهذه ابرز عناوين
اليوم
بوتين يؤكد على تعاون بلاده العسكري مع
الصين وبكين تدعو لخيار السلامه في الازمه
الاوكرانيه
المتحدثه سقوط صاروخ اوكراني في بيلاروسيا
حاله مطريه على معظم المناطق السعوديه
والارصاد تتوقع استمرار فرص الامطار على
مكه حتى الثلاثاء
ومن ملفاتنا في الرابعه كذلك
مع تزايدي شكاوى المستفيدين في السعوديه
الرابعه تفتح ملفات رفض شركات تامين
طبيبات العلاج
الجمارك السعوديه تحبط محاولتي تهريب
قرابه ثلاثه ملايين حبه مخدره عبر منفذي
الربع الخالي والحديث
حياكم الله عقد الرئيس الروسي ونظيره
الصيني قمه عبر تقنيه الفيديو ناقشها
خلالها العلاقات الثنائيه واكد بوتن خلال
كلمته ان تعاون الروسي الصيني يزداد كعامل
استقرار على الساحه الدوليه وقال بوتين ان
التعاون العسكري مع بكين مهم لتعزيز الامن
الاقليمي مشيرا الى العزم على تطويره
امدادات الغاز الروسي الى الصين خلال
العام المقبل في دوره قال الرئيس الصيني
انه بكين مستعده لتطوير التعاون
الاستراتيجي مع موسكو لمواجهه الوضع
المتازم دوليا
اكد الرئيس الصيني ان الطريق السلام سيظل
صعبا لكنه ممكن
ليش الناس
التي تقوم بها الدول الغربيه تمكنت روسيا
والصين من رفع حجم المبادلات التجاريه
بنسبه 25% بهذه الديناميكيه سنحقق هدف
الوصول الى حجم المبادلات بقيمه 200 مليار
دولار سنويا قبل عام 2024
مكانه خاصه في نطاق العلاقات القويه التي
تربط روسيا والصين هذا يساهم في ضمان امني
بلدينا والحفاظ على الاستقرار في المناطق
الرئيسيه
التعاون بين القوات المسلحه الروسيه
والصينيه
برج جونيور
الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه دكتور محمد
مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
من الرياض اولا برايك ما هي دلاله توقيت
هذه القمه بين الرئيسين الروسي
والصيني وكذلك الى اي مذهب هناك اهميه
لعقد هذه القمه بالنسبه للرئيس الروسي
بلادي ميرفت
بدايه الاهميه يعني عاليه جدا واللقاء
الحالي عبر التقنيه الفيديو ليس همم
منفصلا عن السياق السابق هناك تعاون مستمر
بين روسيا والصين وهناك زيارات متبادل
المسؤولين همم الرافعين المستوى وهذا
الامر مرتبط تحديدا بظروف المواجهه
الدائره الان بين روسيا والغرب والتي ترى
فيها الصين ايضا بانها خط متقدم للمواجهه
الحقيقيه والمواجهه الاكثر اهميه التي
تجري بين الولايات المتحده من جهه والصين
من جهه اخرى التعاون الروسي الصيني يمتد
على مجموعه من الملفات وهذه الملفات مهمه
جدا للطرفين همم اولها المجال الاقتصادي
وامتدادات الطاقه من روسيا الى الصين
وحاجه الصين الى هذه الامدادات المحافظه
على ارقام محمد لضمان التطور الاقتصادي
الصيني في مدى استراتي نعم
يبدو ااا اننا فقدنا
الصوت مع الدكتور الدكتور محمد هل تسمعني
جيدا
نعم اسمع جيدا طيب اريد ان اسال ايضا كذلك
على ما قاله الرئيس الصيني في ما يخصكم
بشكل
الاوكرانيه قال بان طريق السلام سيظل صعبا
لكنه ممكنه ما الذي تقراه في هذا التصريح
من قبل الرئيس الصيني الصين هل هي فعلا
متحمسه او دعنا نقول تريد انها هذه الازمه
عن طريق السلام عن طريق الدبلوماسيه ام
هناك ما تستفيد منه وما ستستفيد منه بكين
على خلفيه هذه الازمه يا دكتور
نعم الامر يتوقف على شكل انهاء الازمه
وعلى مخرجات هذه الازمه والنتائج التي
تنجم عنها الصين حددت موقفها من ازمه
اوكرانيا منذ الاسابيع الاولى
لاندلاع هذه المواجهه الكبرى حين قال وزير
الخارجيه الصيني بان الصين تقف على الجانب
الصحيح من التاريخ في هذه المساله حين
كانت اصيل تتعرض لضغوط دوليه للضغط على
روسيا لوقف الاعمال الحربيه في في
اوكرانيا بعد ذلك الموقف الصيني مستمر على
نفس المنوال وهو يتمسك بضروره السلام
والوصول الى حال سياسي لهذه الازمه لكن في
الوقت نفسه هو لا يضغط على روسيا لاجبارها
على حلول لا تناسب مصالحها او لا تناسب
الرؤيه الروسيه للحل في هذه الازمه ولذلك
اسباب عديده اهمها بان الصين تشعر بان هذه
المواجهه التي تجري الان في اوكرانيا هي
خط متقدم للدفاع عن نفسها لانها تتوقع
ازمه اخرى في تايوان وفي محيط الصين في
بحر الصين الجنوبي وتتوقع زياده الضغوط
الغربيه عليها اا بالشكل الذي يجري الان
مع القوه وبالتالي هي ترى بان ما يجري في
اوكرانيا هو النموذج عما سوف تواجهه هي في
المستقبل القريب دكتور همم محمد انا اشكرك
جزيلا شكرا اعتذر لك المشكله كانت لدي انا
في السماعه الخاصه فيني قبل قليل لم استطع
سمعك شكرا جزيلا لك من باريس الدكتور محمد
سيف الدين الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه
شكرا لكم
اعلن المتحدث باسم الكريم لان دي متر
بيسكوي فانا سقوط صاروخ اوكراني في
بيلاروسيا امر مقلق للغايه وان التنسيق
جار بين الجيشين الروسي
واوضح ديسكو فانا عمليه دمج اربع مناطق
جديده في الاتحاد الروسي تجري على قدم
وساق لضمان الامن هناك وفي رده على سؤال
بشان الصحه بوتن قال بيسكوف انها مساله
تتعلق بامن الدوله لكن تواصل بوتين مع
الصحافه لن يكون كما كان قبل كونانا وحول
الانتخابات الرئاسيه كده بيسكو فانه من
المقرر اجراءه الانتخابات الرئاسيه في
نقلت وكاله ريا نفوستي الروسيه للانباء ان
اكليمي لوكاسكو دونتس كانفصاليين اقررا
دستورين جديدين ونشرت الوكاله صوره تصويت
وصور التصويت برلماني لوغان سكودا الغير
معترف بهما دوليا على الدستور الجديد الذي
يسمح بتشكيل الهيئات اللازمه من اجل
التطبيق التدريجي للدستور الروسي وكانت
موسكو قد اعلن الضمه اربعه اقاليم
اوكرانيه رسميه في نهايه سبتمبر الماضيه
تدرس الولايات المتحده ارساله مركباتي
برادلي القتاليه الى اوكرانيا في اطار
المزيد من الدعم العسكري حسبما افادت
وكاله الانباء وذكرت الوكاله انه لم يتم
اتخاذه قرار النهائي بعد وان الوقت الذي
ستكون فيه المركبات جاهزه للعمل لم يتضح
في ما لم يرد تعليق من البيت الابيض بخصوص
ذلك الدعم
صبايا الطائرات روسيه دون طيار ملات شقه
عائله اوكرانيه لتهدد حياه طفلهما رغم
اعتراضها من قوه الدفاع الجوي للهجمات
الروسيه صباح اليوم نشاهد
[موسيقى]
طلب الامين العام لحلفي الناتو ينسيس
توستمبر بارسال المزيدي من الاسلحه
لاوكرانيا وقال لوكاله الاباء الالمانيه
في حوار نهايه العام ان الامر قد يبدو
وكانه مفارقه لكن الدعم العسكريه
لاوكرانيا هو اسرع طريق للسلام مضيفا ان
الرئيس الروسي بلادي مير بوتين لابد وان
يقتنع بانه لن يحقق اهدافه في السيطره على
اوكرانيا وقال انه بالتالي يمكن ان يكون
هناك حل سلمي تفاوضي يضمن سياده اوكرانيا
كدوله ديمقراطيه مستقله
قال رئيس القوات الصاروخيه المضاده
للطائرات في بيلاروسيا ان هناك حاله من
عدم اليقين بشان السبب وراء اطلاق هدف تم
اسقاطه اثناء تحليقه فوق منطقه بريست
الغربيه في بيلاروسيا
واكد في خطاب المصور ان الاداره العسكريه
في منطقه ايفانوفو اصابت هدفا بانظمه دفاع
جوي وصل من الجانب الاوكراني مضيفا ان
هناك اسئله لا تزال قائمه حول هذا الحادث
وتتم دراستهلك وقالت الخارجيه البيلاروسيه
منذ ذلك الحين انها استدعت السفير
الاوكراني للتعبير عن احتجاج شديد وطالبت
اوكرانيا باجراء تحقيق شامل
الاوكراني بانظمه دفاع جوي لا تزال هناك
اسئله حول هذا الحادث ونحن ندرس نسختين
كان اطلاقا غير مقصود لصاروخ موجه
للطائرات بسبب سوء تدريب الطاقه او عط في
الصاروخ او كان استفزادا متعمدا من قبل
القوه المسلحه الاوكرانيه
اعتقلت سلطات الروسيه مهاجرا من اوكرانيا
في القوقاز كان يخطط لهجوم ارهابي بناء
على تعليمات من اجهزه الامن الاوكرانيه
وفق مكتب الامن الفيدرالي الروسي دون
الكشف عن طبيعه الجريمه الارهابيه التي
كان يخطط لها الاوكراني المعتقل الا ان
التهم الموجهه للمهاجر الاوكراني لم تشمل
هذه الفئه من الجرائم التي تتضمن وقائع
التحضير لهجوم ارهابيين فحسب انما ايضا
التجنيد في التنظيمات الارهابيه والدعوه
العامه للارهاب
نقل موقع اكسيوز عن مسؤولين امريكيين ان
البيت الابيض سيرسل مستشار الامن القومي
للقاء الرئيس الامريكي
فرص السلامي مع الفلسطينيين
الرابعه مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل ايضا
القوات البحريه السعوديه والبحرينيه
تختتمان التمرين البحري المشترك جسر 23
حياكم الله من جديد اعلنت الجمارك
السعوديه عن احباط محاولتي باكثر من
مليونين و 900 الف حبه كبتاجون عبر منتدى
الربع الخالي بجنوب السعوديه والحديث
بشمالها حيث تم او حيث تمت محاولات
التهريب عبر اخفائها داخل التجويب كاملات
كهربائيه في ما تم اخفاء الاخرى داخل احدى
الشاحنات القادمه الى السعوديه الهياته
كشفت كذلك مشاهدينا عن القبض على الشخص
المكلف باستقبالها داخل البلاد
[موسيقى]
تستمر وتوقعاته مركز الارصاد السعودي
بتزايد احتماليه هطول الامطار على معظم
مناطق المملكه منها محافظه جده حتى
الاسبوع المقبل بمستويات تتباين بين
المتوسطه والغزيره الى المستوى المؤدي
لجرائم السيول والذي تضاعفت معه حاله
التاهب من مركز الكوارث والازمات للتصدي
ليتبعت الحاله المطريه
ومن جده ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه سلطان
السلمي سلطان مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في
نشرات الرابعه من الرياض يبدو ان الاجواء
اصبحت اجواء الصحه في جده في هذه
اللحظات اريد ان اسال عن الحاله المناخيه
في جده كيف مرت الحاله المطريه ايضا عليها
مستوى الغزاله كذلك سلطان
اهلا بك نايف واهل بكافه مشاهدين قناه
العربيه بالفعل شهدت محافظه جده مساء
البارحه حاله مطريه عباره عن امطار من
متوسطه الى غزيره في انحاء متفرقه من
محافظه جده وتركزت هذه الامطار في المناطق
الشماليه للمحافظه وكذلك الشرقيه وايضا
الجنوبيه تتحدثنا عن مناطق الشماليه
وتحديدا حي البساتين التي نقف في حاليا
وصل منسوب المياه في الى 54 مليمتر كذلك
منطقه المطار وصلت الى 38 مللي متر ارقام
تعتبر متوسطه الى اعليه ايضا تم فيما
يتعلق بالطرق الرئيسيه تتحدث هناك ثيابيه
كبيره تشهدها المحافظه على ان تدخلت امانه
محافظه جده باكثر من 1500 اليه حديثه لشعب
وشفط المياه الذي في مناطق التي شهدت
ارتفاع في منسوب المياه هنا لكن السياديه
كبيره في طرق جده مساء البارحه المحافظه
اغلاق بعض الانفاق منها نفق السلام وبعض
الشوارع لكن تم فتحها بعد ساعات قليله جدا
بعد التعامل معها من قبل الامانه هنالك
انتشار كبير لاليات الدفاع المدني في
منطقه في محافظه جده وكذلك منطقه مكه بشكل
عام اذا اذا تحدثنا من المناطق الساحليه
ايضا لمنطقه مكه شاهدت امطار ام المتوسطه
على غزيره وكذلك العاصمه المقدسه وايضا
محافظه الطائف تم اغلاق الطريقه الهدى
احترازيا ومن ثم اعاده فتحه بشكل كبير
نتحدث ان هذه الحاله المطريه سوف تستمر
الى يوم الثلاثاء عباره عن امطار همم
مصحوبه ببرد وانعدام للرؤيه وهي امطار من
المتوسطه الى همم تحدثنا عن المناطق
الجنوبيه في محافظه جده وتحديد الحيه
الامير فواز شهد اربعه ارتفاع في منسوب
المياه وصل الى 34 من لا يظهر هنالك
احتماليه له الامطار بعد ثلاث ساعات او
ساعتين من الان بحسب المركز الوطني
للارصاد الذي يتوقع من خلال الساعات
القادمه ان يكون هنالك فرصه هطول الامطار
مشابهه لمحدث لمحافظه جده مساء البارحه
لذلك هنالك يعني نشر للتحذيرات بشكل مستمر
على مواقع التواصل خاصه بالمركز الوطني
للارصاد وانا لك تحضيرات كذلك من الدفاع
المدني وكذلك شهاده محافظه جده للمره
الاولى تحذير عبر الهواتف النقاله وكان هو
عباره عن تحديث ذكي لتنويه المواطنين
المقيمين في جده لعدم الخروج من المنازل
والذهاب الاوديه ومجالس السيناء سلطان
خليني اسالك يعني سؤال من من معرفتك انت
بم بمحافظه
ام انها للمره الاولى في تقلبات جديده او
حاله تعتقد انها جديده على محافظه جده في
ما يخص درجه الحراره في ما يخص طول
الامطار ايضا كذلك استمراريته وغزارتها
ايضا كذلك وباختصار السلطه
بطبيعه الحال في في محافظه جده كل عام مثل
هذا التوقيت تشهد احاله او مطريه من
متوسطه الى غزيره لكن هذه الحاله تشهدناها
مساء البارحه لم تكن مثل حالات الاخرى
وتحديدا خلال اسابيع الماضيه التي شهدت
جده وارتفع منسوب المياه فيها الى 187
مللي في المناطق الجنوبيه هذه الحاله كانت
محدوده جدا هذا المطر لساعات محدده وتعديل
ساعه و45 دقيقه تم التعامل معها بشكل جيد
لم تشكل ضرر كبير سوى في مناطق محدده لتضر
بعض المركبات لكن كانت مركبات يعني محدوده
جدا وتم التعامل معها من قبل الاليات
الخاصه
بالامانه جدا لكن هذه الحاله كانت طبيعيه
جدا لكن الحاله الاستثنائيه التي شهادتها
جدا خلال الثلاثه الماضيه او اربع اسابيع
الماضيه هي كانت الحاله الاستثنائيه اذا
وصل منسوب المياه فيها الى 187 دينا اشكرك
جزيل شكرا على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل
من جده مراسل العربيه سلطان اااه السلمي
ومنه انتقل الى الخبير في التغير المناخيه
الدكتور منصور المزروعي الذي يلتحق بينه
هو الاخر من مدينه جده دكتور منصور مرحبا
بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض قبل
قليل ان ختمت مع المناسب بسؤال عن همم
الحاله المطريه والجويه التي تعيشها جدا
وسالتها بشاهده شهد هذا العام تغيرا
مناخيا همم او حتى في نسب الامطار هذا
العام جدا مثلا سجلت منسوب المياه فيها
اكثر من 180 ملليمتر تقريبا وهي للمره
الاولى همم حتى على المستوى العالمي عندما
نشاهد الولايات المتحده وحاله الصقيع
الموجوده فيها باعتقد انها غير غير مجهوده
في وضع تغير مناخ كبير دكتور منصور كيف
ممكن نفسره وانت ك- خبير في هذا الملف
حقيقه التغير مناخي ليس فقط في امريكا
والسعوديه تغير مناخيه حاصل في العالم كله
حاصل اول في تغير مناخي ولم يمكن الناس
حقيقه عندهم اعتقاد بتغير مناخي الان
الوضع صار حقيقه وصار في عندي جفاف في
اوروبا حصل فيه عندي امطار في الصيف
السعوديه في الصيف اول مره تحصل عندي صحيح
الان في امريكا شيء غريب جدا وحتى الامطار
اللي حصل في جده هذه على فكره هي تغير
المناخير لماذا لانه الامطار اصلا غير
معتاده في شهر ديسمبر معتاده فين في شهر
نوفمبر نوفمبر احنا تقريبا شهر واحد فرق
انا لكن انا ودي اقول انه جامعه الملك عبد
العزيز عند مركز تغير مناخي وهي تدرس
حاليا
بالخبره اللي عندها اللي هي الحالات
المتطرفه هذه والجامعه حقيقه كلمتنا وقالت
لابد انكم تدرس
يعني حقيقه وجدنا من ضمن الامور انه في
عندي تسخين في المحيط الهندي وعند تسخين
في بحر الاحمر بحر الاحمر هذا صار فيه
تسخين غريب والان مثلا زي الحادث اللي
امبارح هذه اللي في جده هذه اللي حتى
الدفاع المدني سوى
التحذير من عن طريق الجوالات هذه بصراحه
يعني اول شيء اشكر الدفاع المدني على هذا
الخطوه وايضا كمان اشكر اللي هو مركز
الوطني ارصاد واتمنى ايضا من جميع الجهه
الحكوميه اتباع اللي هو تعليماته اللي هو
همم
على فكره يعني انا ليش اتكلم معك صوت مجلس
اداره في المركزه ومعاه الوزير معه الوزير
في الموضوع هذا من زمان طيب والدوله ما
حقيقه صرفت عليه مليارات
يا دكتور لكن خلينا نفهم انت تكون في حاله
تسخين في المحيط الهندي وفي حاله تسخين
ايضا في البحر الاحمر غير مسبوقه وغير
مشهوده
هل يعني هذا انه في ارتفاع في درجه حراره
الارض يا دكتور وليش وين ممكن توصل اصلا
يعني الحراره الان حقيقه يعني لو نظرنا
يعني من خلال الدراسات اللي عملناها في
التغير المناخي وجدنا انه قد تصل الى 56
درجه لكن في الصيف يعني
حصلت يعني قبل سابقا في جده
لكن تحصل في الصيد
نغير نمط الحياه في السعوديه وفي المناطق
هذه لكن كيف التسخين على البحر الاحمر
والخليه هذه حقيقه ليست اليوم المحيط
الهندي يعني هو يعتبر كله
يعني
فهي ما هي نتيجه هذا اليوم لكن وليده ست
سنوات ماضيه وصار فيها تسخين وجمع تسخين
وصار عندي الحراره هذه الحاله المطريه
دكتور هل تستطيع تقييم الوضع بان الوضع
التغير المناخي اليوم سواء انا ال- ال-
المحل اللي موجود عندنا حتى على مستوى
العالم هل هو وضع صادم مخيف بمعنى ان يعني
الوضع المناخي والتغير المناخي سبق
التوقعات للدراسات والابحاث اللي دائما
تتحدث عن التغير المناخي سبقها بسنوات
تتكلم يعني متقدمه
حقيقه يعني لو تكلمنا تغير مناخي انا
خبيره التغير صحيح لكن الامام جامعه الملك
عبد العزيز كان عنده مركز تميز بعد التغير
المناخي وكان اول مركز على على مستوى
السعوديه الان المركز الوطني للارصاد عمل
مركز تغير مناخي جديد ونتمنى باذن الله
تعالى له نجاح والتوفيق لان هذا هو المركز
الحقيقه يعمل الدراسات المستقبليه يفترض
انه كل الجامعات السعوديه تتعاون مع
المركز اللي هو عن طريق الغربيه
والمياه والزراعه والوزاره يعني هذا
المركز ليس يعني لها يعني ولكن عملته بناء
على توجيهات العليا من صاحب السمو الملكي
الامير محمد بن سلمان اللي هو يكون مركز
اقليمي للتغير نعم ممتاز خليني اختم في
الاخر في في ما يخص المركز كثير في يعني
في موقع التواصل الاجتماعي هو يعني دائما
يعشقون تصوير الاجواء الممطره والثلوج او
غيره بيروحين يمكن الاماكن يا دكتور صعبه
وانت سعر طبعا في حسابك في اا في في تويتر
برايك مفترض انه يصير في تعاون مع المركز
الوطني للارصاد بينهم وبين هؤلاء الهواتف
كيف ممكن يختموهم
يعني انا اتصور
اخي العزيز انه هو هذول وهم سند المركز
الوطني للارصاد طبعا سابقا في 2019 كان
كان يعترضون على الهيئه العامه للارصاد في
حمايه البيئه لانهم مخرجات الهيئه كانت
يعني سلبيه لكن الان احنا العتاب 2023
والمركز تطور وحسن والان هذول اللي هو
حقيقه يعني ممكن يكون دهمين للمركز من
جميع الامور
للمعلوميه ترى سابقا كان في اسمه نادي
الهواه كان اول رئيس الفقري هو صاحب السمو
الملكي الامير فيصل من خالد بن سلطان بن
عبد العزيز امير منطقه الحدود الشماليه
اتمنى من المركز انه يعني
تبقى موجود يفعل الان واتمنى
بشكل صحيح نعم اشكرك شكرا جدا
خبير التغير المناخي الدكتور منصور
الدكتور
اختتم في البحرين التمرين والبحري الثنائي
المختلط جسر 23 بين القوات البحريه
السعوديه وسلاح البحريه البحريني التمرين
شهيد تنفيذ عدد من الفرضيات التي تهدف
لرفع قدره القتاليه لقوات البلدين في
مختلف العمليات البحريه
[موسيقى]
وصلت الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بالاسطول الغربي في جده سفينه جلاله الملك
الدرعيه والتي تعد السفينه الثانيه ضمن
مشروع السروات الذي يضمه 5 سفن قتاليه
ويهدف الى رفع مستوى الجاهزيه البحريه
وتعزيز الامن البحري في المنطقه وحمايه
المصالح الاستراتيجيه الحيويه
من حبنا صف المشروع السروات ينضم الينا
العميد البحري ركن عبد الله الشهري مدير
المشروع مكتب الاشراف والمتابعه بالمملكه
اسبانيا عميد عبد الله مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض وصلت سفنتان حتى
الان من هذا المشروع مشروع مشروع البحريه
الاكبر وهو مشروع السنوات اريد ان اسال ما
الذي ستضيفه هذه القطعه البحريه او السفن
البحريه الجديده الى منظومه البحريه
السعوديه
السلام عليكم مساء الخير سعيد جدا لكم
معكم اولا ااا نهنا قيادتنا الرشيده وعلى
راسها مولاي خادم الحرمين الشريفين ولي
عهد الامين رئيس مجلس الوزرافه سمو الملكي
الامير محمد بن سلمان وزير الدفاع صاحب
سمو الملكي الامير خالد بن سلمان والقياده
القوات البحريه
الثانيه
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
تعتبر
الاحدث من طرازها من نوعها طراز خورفيت في
العالم من ناحيه القدرات القتاليه وكثافه
النيران
السفن تملك منظومات قتاليه ومنظومات
تسريحه قادره على مجابهه مختلف التهديدات
ولذلك هي تعتبر سفن متعدده المهام قادره
على كافه تهديدات الجويه وتهديدات السطحيه
وتهديدات تحت السطحيه اضافه الى مكافحه
الحروب الالكترونيه
الجديده ومنها جلاله الملك الدرعيه همم
كيف ممكن نقارنها بالسفن الحربيه الكبرى
اللي تمتلكها بعض الدول مثل الولايات
المتحده او حتى ايضا بعض الدول همم اوروبا
همم السفن المشروع الثروات همم هي من طراز
كورفت لكن منظومات التسليح الموجوده على
سفن الكورد والصفه المشروع
تضاهي في كثافه النيران والقدره الناريه
للسفن الاعلى منها ااا
حجما او طرازا
كالفرقعات او او ما شابه ثاني
اللي يعطيه سفن مشروع السروات
القيمه المضافه انها تحمل قوه ناريه عاليه
منظومات تسليح مختلفه همم على وحده قتاليه
تعتبر اقل حجما وهذا يعطيها ديناميكيه
ويعطيها سرعه عاليه المناوره
وانتخاب المواقع اللازمه لتنفيذ المهاب
العسكريه سواء كانت المياه ضاحكه في
المياه الدوليه الاقليميه او حتى فيها ال
بحار
هنا انه صمت السفينه بناء على معايير
ومقاييس عالميه جدا اييه تسمح للسفينه
لتنفيذ مهامها العسكريه في اي منطقه بحريه
في العالم او فقط دورها مقتصر على المناطق
البحريه ولا ايضا ايضا لها ادوار اخرى في
مراقبه الجويه وغير عميد عبد الله
احسنت سؤال جيد جدا بالنسبه لمنظمات
الموجوده على السفينه فيها نظم الاستكشاف
والبحث والمرافقه والمستشعرات المخادرات
اللي موجوده عليها
ولهم الالتقاط الاليكتروني هذه قادره على
البحث
ورصد الاهداف سواء في البحر او حتى في
الاجواء همم
الاجواء
المناطق الداخليه
نعم الاجواء البريه لان ضمن ضمن
يعني بامكانك انك تكتشف الاهداف على مستوى
او على مدى بعيد جدا همم ممكن مشاركه
الاهداف هذه مع القوات البحريه اخرى
مشاركه معك همم مهمه الواجب او مشاركتها
اساسا معه وحدات في القياده والسيطره في
ااا
سيطره في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
قادره على اصابه الاهداف في البحر وايضا
رصد الاهداف واصابتها واستهدافها على
اليابسه همم المنظمات الغطائيه اللي
موجوده على الرسول صلى الله عليه جدا
منظومات الصواريخ
كثير من حوض بناء السفن مشروع السنوات همم
فرناندو الينا العميد البحري ركن عبدالله
فقط
ولي العهد
المستمره من قياده القوات البحريه والحرص
على نجاح مشروع الصرافات من قبل المعلقات
اسبانيا
[موسيقى]
تشهد العاصمه السعوديه الرياض منذ صباح
الساعات الاولى من اليوم هطول امطار خفيفه
الى متوسطه وكان مركز الوطني للارصاد قد
اصدر تنبيها متقدما على منطقه الرياض
يستمر حتى الثانيه من مساء غدا السبت حول
هطول امطار متوسطه الى غزيره
من شمال الرياض ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
عبد المحسن الحربي عبد المحسن مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
الله والاجواء عبد المحسن من زمان ما شفتك
بهذه الصوره الحلوه
ههه
الاجواء رائعه والحقيقه نايف انا يبغى لي
كورس باستخدام هذه المظله
في الرياض من فتره طويله بعد هذه الامطار
ههه
بعد هذه الامطار الغزيره اللي بدات من
صباح هذا اليوم
وبعدها انتشر اهل الرياض بشكل كبير جدا في
مناطق مختلفه للاستمتاع بهذه الاجواء وسط
ايضا تحضيرات من قبل الدفاع المدني وهيئه
الارصاد لكافه المواطنين والمقيمين الذين
ذهبوا للاستمتاع بهذه الاجواء في الصوره
من همم بعض المواقع المواقع كثيره جدا
التي يفضل الناس الذهاب اليها هذه واحد من
مواقع همم التي هي في الطريق لمنتزه
الثمامه همم البري همم
والشاهد البعض يستمتع بال همم بركوب
الدبابات والخيول وغيرها من همم النشاط
همم مختلفه في الحقيقه نايف الان الطرق
مزدحمه بشكل كبير جدا في الاتجاه الى
المنتزهات البريه وايضا همم كل هذه
الازدحامات تاتي في ظل هذه التحذيرات التي
صدرت من الدفاع المدني والارصاد وكافه
الجهات الحكوميه ايضا هناك تنظيم كبير جدا
من قبل الجهه الامنيه والمروريه حتى الان
همم ول الحمد لم يسجل اي من حالات
همم التي اضطر الدفاع المدني الى التعامل
معها بشكل كبير جدا همم في همم هذه
المناطق المختلفه في الرياض نايف هنالك
بعض الاشخاص الذين يودون المشاركه معنا
وهم يستمتعون بهذه الاجواء في الحقيقه هو
في سيارته طيب اداء بس عشان المطر عشان
المطر طيب كلمني عن الاجواء اليوم كيف
يستمتع اهل الرياض في هذه الاجواء الممتره
اول شيء طلع عمرك نحمد الله ونشكره اول
شيء ابارك لكم على الرحمه اللي طال عمرك
شاسعه على المملكه التربيه السعوديه ونحمد
الله من وامان في ظل سيدي خادم الحرمين
الشريفين ولي عهده ونحمد الله ونشكره على
كل حال احنا طال عمرك انت نجزه فلو قاتل
الحلوه هذه ونطلع طال عمرك للبر ونطلع
للمخيم ونطلع
للمنتزهات زي ما انت شايف طال عمرك
نهار تمشي بالسياره وبالليل في المخيم في
المخيم بالضبط
الله الله يحييكم وعيوننا لكم والله يطول
عمرك الاجواء حلوه يا نايف وهذي عزيمه على
الهواء لك في المساء ذهب للمخيم همم
حلوه النفسيه حلوه والناس كلها طالعه
تستمتع في هذه الاجواء الرائعه همم
الترفيه وايضا حتى
المطاعم الاماكن كلها
الحقيقه المطر يشكل حاله همم حاله ترفيهيه
بحداته لكافه المواطنين والمقيمين ايضا في
ظل التحذيرات التي تحدثت عنها قبل قليل
وهمم الحرص على الالتزام بهذه الشروط
والقواعد التحذيريه للابتعاد عن اماكن
السيول وغيرها من الاماكن الخطره التي
عاده ما تحصل فيها حوادث لا سمح الله ولكن
حتى الان الكل مستمتع في ظل اجواء رائعه
وهمم في ضل ايضا عدم تسجيل اي اصابات همم
في همم الرياض وفي مناطقها المختلفه
احنا ما نعرف كيف نتواصل معه عشان نجيبها
اليوم والعزيمه للانتقابلتها عني عبد
المحسن لكن شكرا جزيلا لك من شمالا
الرياضي العربي عبد المحسن هو راح المخيم
خلاص شكرا لك ههه
الرابعه مستمره ربيع بعد قليل
مزارعوه فيفا جنوب السعوديه يواصل هنا حصد
البن استعدادا لبدء المهرجان السنوي مطلع
العام المقبل
حياكم الله من جديد اصبحت الشكاوى ضد
شركات التامين الطبي مول في نهايته كل عام
مع ازدياد طلبات العلاج ضمن تغطيه التامين
الصحيه السنويه وقبل انتهاء الامر الذي
اثار التساؤلات الكثيرين حول نظاميه ما
تقوم به شركات التامين الصحي والاجراءات
التي تتخذها عند رفض اي طلب طبي
مع نهايه كل عام تتزايد شكاوي المستفيدين
في السعوديه عن رفض شركات التامين الصحي
طلبات المستفيدين لاجراء الفحوصات الطبيه
والصرف الادويه لدى المستشفيات الخاصه في
عدد من الاشياء التي لا يحق لشركه تامين
رفضها وهي الامراض المزمنه الامراض العاده
همم العاديه او المتكرره والحالات الطارئه
الكشفيات الاشعه وهذه ما نص عليها وثيقه
التامين التي يجب على شركه تامين عدم
رفضها او عدم همم والتجاوب معها باقصى
سرعه ممكنه واقصى وقد حددت يعني اللائحه
التنفيذيه لضماء للنظام الضمان الصحي ااا
60 دقيقه للرد على طلبات المستفيد من
شركات التامين الطبي في هذا الامر
يستغرق رد مجلس الضمان الصحي على الشكاوي
الالكترونيه للمطالبات الطبيه 10 ايام
فيما يرى مختصون انه يجب على شركات
التامين الصحي لشعار المستفيدين من
التامين الصحي باسباب رفض الطلبات بعكس ما
يجري حاليا لدى بعض الشركات التي ترد برفض
الطلبات خلال دقائق وجود رفض من الشركات
التامين هذا موجود في جميع انحاء العالم
بس اتوقع من حق كل كل شخص مامن عليه انه
يكون عنده توضيح كامل من شركه التامين او
من الجهه من عليه انه سبب الرفد زي اي
بنوك همم اي جهه ثانيه يصير هو عنده وضوح
كامل ليش تمر الرفض وكيف ممكن يعالجه
فتوقع في مرحله مهمه تصير في ش تامين واظن
المجلس الضمان الصحي قائم بدوره الاكمل
الوجه في هذا الشيء عندهم الرقم المجاني
وعندهم الموقع وعندهم الايميل وممكن
للتواصل مباشره تطورات تاريخيه قادمه
لقطاع التامين الصحي في السعوديه بعد
موافقه مجلس الوزراء السعودي على تاسيس
شركه الصحه القابضه والموافقه على تنظيم
مركز التامين الصحي الوطني الساعي لمنح
التامين الصحي لجميع المواطنين بشكل مجاني
من الرياض نواف عزيز العربيه
ينضب علينا هنا في الاستديو دكتور ناصر
الجهني المتحدث باسم مجلس الضمان الصحي
دكتور ناصر حياك الله الشوط الرابع من
الرياض
ليش تزداد شكاوي الناس من التامين طبي من
الشركات التامين الطبي مع نهايه كل سنه
ليش هالحاله تتكرر كل سنه نعم طبعا نهايه
كل سنه يعني لو تشوف بالنسبه للمواسم
الناس راجعين الاجازات الصيفيه الموسم
موسم تقلب اجواء والناس كثير للاسف تمرض
وتحتاج زياره الطوارئ والتنويم ايضا كثير
من وثائق التامين تجدد في بدايه سنه في
واحد واحد على نهايه وثاق التامين يمكن
لبعض يبغى يزور
المقدمين الخدمه والمستشفيات من اجل انه
يحصل على الخدمات قبل لا تنتهي الوثيقه
نعم نعم من حققه على نهايه السنه ابدا
يزيد الاستخدام على بطاقه التامين حاجه
الناس لزياره المستشفيات نسب الرف اللي
همم طلبات الموافقات هي تقريبا ثابته كل
السنه ولكن زياده استخدام الوثائق وزيارات
يعني يزيد العدد المطلق ممتاز طيب مع هذا
الرفض اللي اللي يصير في في حالات كثير
مثل ما سمعنا قبل قليل وحتى ايضا ما
تستعرض في موقع التواصل الاجتماعي
ينطرح السؤال هل تتدخل شركات التامين
الطبيه في قرارات ال- ال- الدكاتره مثلا
في المستشفيات بمعنى انه لو دكتور مثلا
قال المفروض انه تسوي العمليه الفلانيه
وتاخذ الدوال الفلاني لكن الشركه مثلا
شركه التامين رفضت هذه اعتبر التدخل ولا
لا اذا كانت يحق لشركه تامين تدخل في
قرارات الاطباء اذا كان هناك مسوغ طبي
ومبرر الطبي لهذه الاجراءات الطبيه طيب
ولا يحق لشركه التامين وهذا
من شركات التامين هل هذه الحاله تستاهلها
سؤال ممتاز جدا طبعا اول شيء في عمليه
الطلبات الموافقات او شيء يجب ان تكون همم
طلبات مكتمله فيها التشخيص واضح همم
فحص الطبي للمريض تاريخ المرضي للمريض هذه
يجب ان تكون جميعها مكتمله ااه الاصل انه
شركه التميمي ما تدخل في راي الطبيب الا
اذا كان مخالف بالاستيراد على الممارسات
الطبيه والادله الطبيه العلميه قام مجلس
الضمان الصحي باصدار 50 دليل طبي خلال هذه
السنه ونعتزم اصدار الوصول الى 200 لطب
باذن الله في 2023 طيب دكتور ناصر في ناس
كثير ترفض
وخلينا نقول في ناس كثير في ناس ترفض مثلا
طلبات العلاج لهم اا وفي لحظات ترفض هذه
الطلبات الهجوم ما يشعرونهم بالسبب هنا
يفتح في بالك سؤال انه ممكن السبب طبعا
اللي هي نهايه السنه دائما زي ما ذكرنا في
البدايه انه السبب بسبب الكوست عالي همم
شركه التامين بتوضيح اسباب الرفض حسب
لائحه حمايه المستفيدين الاصدار وتعاقب
وتخالق جميع شركات تامين التي تقوم شركه
التامين اذا ما اشعرت بسبب الرفض نعم نعم
طبعا احنا اشكر الاخ اللي كان ضيف في ال-
في التقرير همم انا احب اذكر برقم رقم
التواصل الموحد لمجلس الضمان 92,000
77 نرحب بجميع الاتصالات
وصلنا عدد المكالمات لمجلس الضمان السنه
الماضيه 500,000 هذه السنه وصلنا الى
المليون وهذا يدل على الناس بدات تعرف كيف
تضمن حقوقها وكيف تصل همم الى مجلس الضمان
ايضا تطبيق مجلس الضمان انا ودي استغل هذه
الفرصه اني اذكر الناس انه تطبيق مجلس
الضمان الذي تم تحديث المؤخرا على جوالات
الذكيه يوضح حقوق المستفيدين الخدمات
المغطاه الغير مغطاه الاستثناءات ايضا
طلبات الموافقات والتحديث عليها وايضا
والجزء المهم هو رفع الشكاوى يتم رفع جميع
الشكاوى عن طريق التطبيق على الشكاوى
خليني اسال عن عدد
الضمان الصحي هذا السنه فيه تقديرات معينه
السنه الماضيه وصلنا 85,000 شكوى في السنه
هذه السنه هذه السنه وصلنا 25,000 همم
متوقع في 2023 ناصر 200 الف شكوى في السنه
وكم عالجته من هذا تقريبا
نعالجها كلها طبعا احنا وصلنا عالجناها
كلها 99% تقريبا خمسه زي كده
رصدت مخالفات مش شركات التامينات الطبي
مخالفات وايضا اصدار غرامات على شركات
تامين بدايه هذا العام وصلنا غرامات على
14 شركه تامين بما قيمته همم مليونين 600
الف ريال وفي ايضا مخالفات قائمه الشركات
التامين الطبيه همم هل هي متجاوبه سريعه
بالرد على الشكاوه من خلال تقييمكم انتم
من خلال الشكاوي اللي توصلكم طالما انها
فديه معناته انه الحاله ما تتغير
رد يكون متاخر مش مشتري يعني ماذا يحتمل
انه ازداد الشكاوي ثقه الناس في مجلس
الضمان وفي انه اذا اشتكى حتى يجي في في
المستفيد دائما يحرس التواصل مع الجهات
المنظمه خلينا نستغل فرصه اتكلم عن منصه
نفيس وفي السابق الوضع الساب
كانت كل شركه تامين عندها منصه مختلفه
وايضا مقدمين الخدمه يرفعون على منصات
مختلفه ولا فيه اطلاع مباشر من مجلس
الضمان على هذه المنصات يعني الاطلاع ياخذ
وقت الان منصه نفيسه التي انطلقت في ابرول
من هذه السنه
جميع شركات التامين تقريبا وصلنا الان 80%
من القطاع مقدمه كلهم على منصه نفيسه الان
عندنا اطلاع مباشر ريال تايم يعني بالوقت
بالثانيه على جميع الطلبات الموافقات ما
يقبل منها ما يرفض لماذا يرفض مش الفحوصات
اللي اكثر شيء ترفض الى اخره
البيانات المبدايه تورينا انه فيتامينات
طلبات الفيتامينات هي اكثر شيء
متوقع لانه وهي تختلف من المستشفى
المستشفى بصراحه يعني الطلبات الرفض او
القبول يعني في المستشفيات دائما دائما
وفي اخرى يعني احيانا تقبل وما تقبل هذا
الشيء اللي احنا الان عبر منصه نفيس رح
نتمكن من الاطلاع عليه مين مقدمين الخدمه
والمستشفيات اللي يرفعون بشكل صحيح يرفعون
بشكل غير مكتمل من شركات تامين اللي نسب
الرفقها والى اخرها دكتور انا اشكرك جزيل
الشكر على قبول الدعوه على الحضور معنا
هنا في استديو الرابعه الدكتور ناصر
الجهني المتحدث باسم مجلس الضمان الصحي
شكرا جزيلا شكرا
في مدينه جازان يوصل المزارعون في المناطق
الجبليه السعوديه حسب الثمار للبدء في
بيعها وتصديرها والمشاركه ايضا في مهرجان
البن مطلع العام المقبل و تشهد السعوديه
حاليا احد افضل المواسم لحصاد البن بسبب
هطول الامطار وزياده المحاصيل وسط مبادرات
لدعم زراعه البني بانواعه من احد مزارع في
منطقه جازان مراسل العربيه اسامه القاسم
مساء الخير يا اسامه اترك الصوره والكلمه
لك ونقول انا عندك
اهلا وسهلا نايف تحيه طيبه قناه العربيه
اقف اليوم في احدى اكبر مزارع البن
السعودي هنا في فيفا جنوب غربي السعوديه
الفلاسفه يقولون نحتسي كوب القهوه وعامه
الناس يقولون نشرب كوب القهوه اما هنا في
فيفا فانت على موعد مع احتساء وشرب القهوه
وسط هذه الاجواء الساحره هنا على يميني
جبال فيفا بمدرجاتها الزراعيه وهنا في هذه
المزرعه التي تنتج اجود انواع البن
السعودي طبعا الانتاج المحلي للبني يتجاوز
ال 500 طن سنويا والذي يشارك به المزارعون
في مهرجان البن بنسخته العاشره القادمه في
منتصف يناير وبانتهاء ايضا ينتهي في نهايه
فبراير هذا المهرجان يمثل الكبير جدا
للمزارعين هنا في مناطق جنوب غربيه
السعوديه لانهم يبيعون محاصيل لهم
الممتازه في هذه الفتره طبعا كما اسبقت
انه محاصيل هذا العام ممتازه جدا بسبب
هطول الامطار وايضا لرعايه المزارعين
حسب نايف ثقافه المزارعين هنا وهنا ما
زالت ثقافه قويه جدا بموضوع انه الاهتمام
بشتله البن واهتمام شخصي لا عمال لا جهات
لا شيء المزارع بمنزله بمزرعته هو من
يحافظ على مزرعته دائما وابدا بعض
المزارعين تاريخ مزارعهم يتجاوز ال 500
عام ابا عن جد طبعا البن الخولاني دخل ضمن
قائمه التراث
الشهرين همم وهو بالتاكيد طيب انا بس عندي
نقطه اخيره نايف اللي هي اتفاقيات حصلت في
جازان جنوب غربيه السعوديه في موضوع انشاء
مصانع القهوه والشركه السعوديه القهوه
بالتعاون مع الهيئه الملكيه بجازان باقامه
مصنع همم لانشاء القهوه السعوديه في
المدينه الاقتصاديه يسعدنا الان يكون معي
صاحب هذه المزرعه السعيده اهلا وسهلا تفضل
معنا
حياك الله بدايه عم اسعد اليوم وانت احد
المزارعين القدامى في فيفا وهذا ما شاء
الله ال ال المحصول طبعا هذا المحصول هو
اثناء نضج البن هنا في جبال فيفا حدثنا
اليوم عم اسعد عن مشاعركم مع انكم جايين
يشاركون ايضا في مهرجان البن بعد ايام
حياك الله يا مرحبا الف في مزرعتنا
الكائنه في جبل الشراحيب فيفا في الحقيقه
يعني الوقت الموسم الجيناء يعني من واحد
10 الى 12 ميلاد
بالنسبه للبن الخولاني السعودي هو ينافس
عالميا بجوده البن
وبطبيعه المنطقه وطبيعه التربه والحمد لله
يعني المنتوج السنه دي ممتاز جدا ومن فضل
الله يعني انا بالنسبه لي اني اتابع
المزرعه باستمرار ما اخلي فراغ طيب يعني
الشجره لازم تكون صديق الشجره طيب مسعد
السؤال الاخير انتو اليوم ما شاء الله احد
اكبر مزارعين احد اكبر من زرع اليوم في
فيفا كل كلمه اخيره فقط المزارعين هناك
سريع انا اسامه
ان يكون مهتمين بالشجره القهوه
باستمرار واحياء المدرجات من جديد بحيث من
لها اكثر من 1,000 سنه يعني المنطقه وهي
تحمل البن الخولاني السعودي والان رجعت من
جديد الحمد لله يعني شكرا لك عم اسعد اذا
نايف اتمنى لو كان الوقت طويل ايضا ناخذكم
في دوله
لكن ما عندنا وقت كافي شكرا جزيلا لك من
جزاء من جبال فيفا براس العربيه اسامه
القاسم شكرا جزيلا لك
الى العناوين
بوتين يؤكدوا على تعاون بلاده العسكري مع
الصين وبكين تدعوا لخيار السلامه في
الازمه الاوكرانيه
حاله مطريه على معظم المناطق السعوديه
والارصاد وتتوقع استمرار فرص الامطار على
مكه حتى الثلاثاء
مع تزايد وشكاوي المستفيدين في السعوديه
الرابعه تفتحوا ملفات ربطه شركات تامين
طبيبات العلاج
الجمارك السعوديه تحبط محاوله اي تهريب
قرابه الثلاثه ملايين حبه مخدر عبر منفذيه
الربع الخالي والحديثه
شكرا لكم
مزيد من الاخبار والمعلومات نهايه الرابعه
اعود والقاكم يوم غد في رعايه
[موسيقى]